so thanks for having me I am just to
give you a little background on myself
so I love talking about this stuff and
if you've talked me a little bit already
I've talked a few people you know that I
have a big passion for helping teams
work better and so just a little
background for me to give you the
context of where I'm coming from so I've
been a developer for quite a while since
the early 90s basically so but I've been
doing this for a while and about ten
years ago I started leading teams it
wasn't on purpose necessarily it was
more from the standpoint of I really
wanted to help the team protect the team
if you will be there to stand in between
the team having a hard understanding of
what the business needed and the
business having a hard time
communicating to the team so I was one
of those people that was able to
communicate and get that bridge between
the two teams to to be there and so what
was interesting though is I was like
okay this is cool I'm you know felt like
I was doing my job
doing good things and then the next
thing you know I ended up turning into
that very bad leader as well the one I
was trying to protect them from and what
was interesting is I had discovered
something that I want to share with you
today about our instincts but before we
go there I do want to share with you a
story about a small company that you may
be familiar with so what's interesting
is this company Southwest Airlines
you're probably familiar with if not
they're one of my favorite airlines I
highly recommend them to fly if you're
gonna go flying somewhere and when they
were a regional airline airline I was
told this story a few years ago so I'm
not sure when the when this meeting
happened but there were a regional
airline and they had the entire
leadership come together to talk about
as a company what could they do to
empower their teams to encourage their
teams to give that one principle for
their teams to kind of rally around with
their discretionary time what was that
one thing that they could all work
towards I believe the question was
phrased similar to this where they're
talking about what metric could they do
to help the team kind of understand
their you know discretionary time
they've got some free time what can they
do to help the team grow because their
goal was to obviously beat the
competition so what was that question
what was the answer to that question
that they came up with and normally this
is where I would have the audience
interact but obviously we're short on
time so I'll just give you the answer so
what they came
with was time in the air which kind of
makes sense probably right like a lot of
people when they answer this they'll say
customer service like what's the one
thing that Southwest is known for what
are they focus on but it was actually
the time in the air and this is still to
this day the only airline that I've ever
seen where I've seen a pilot come out of
the cockpit as I'm leaving the plane and
go back and help the flight attendants
clean up garbage on the floor so again
they've been able to instill in their
entire organization this principle of we
need to make sure that what we're doing
is working towards this one goal so that
was cool for Southwest that's awesome
you know but I don't work for an airline
and so I was a little discouraged by
this because I work with knowledge teams
like teams that work with knowledge work
it's work that's normally hidden it's
really hard to determine kind of what
we're working on a lot of times and so I
was a little discouraged and so in the
last three or four years I've become a
very avid student of lean and agile I'm
still learning a lot as the way I put it
for sure and as as I was getting into
that and learning more about that I
wanted to find that metric that would be
applicable for knowledge work teams and
so what I've come what I've come to
realize is one of the metrics that is
tracked in Kanban systems is called flow
efficiency so if you're not familiar
with flow efficiency the simple
definition that I use is basically
determining how much time of the total
time that was spent on an item was you
actually or your team actually adding
value to that item so not the time that
it was sent they're waiting for approval
not the time that it was sitting there
for you know some other blocker if you
will but the time that you're actually
adding value to that item and then the
next question I usually get is okay well
how much you know what is that like how
how what's the average in America or
whatever well unfortunately I don't I
don't have a number for that
but fortunately about two to three years
ago I think it was they had a study that
was done in Germany and they took all
the top 500 teams which is essentially
the S&P 500 but in Germany and they
measured their flow efficiency so since
we do have a couple more minutes here I
wanted to ask this anyone want to guess
what that efficiency would have been
where flow efficiency is if it's a low
number it's a bad number so you're not
as efficient obviously as a higher
number you'd be more efficient as a team
doesn't want to take a guess real quick
before we move on any brave souls out
there five it's really close so they
came back with four to six percent
usually I get people guessing 25% 50%
you know whatever but we're we're a lot
lower on that than we think but then the
next question I get is well that can't
be possible Paul I am busy all the time
right like I'm super busy I'm always
doing something I'm always you know
working on something I come into work
every day and there's always something
to do it's not like I'm sitting here
without work to do so what does that
mean well that's what this today is big
ideas about and I only have time to
share one of them with you
but this is what I love doing is helping
teams understand that their natural
instincts for how they work is actually
causing more delay and how you get your
work done and so that's where you want
to start learning how you can fight
against those natural instincts and
improve how you can get in the state of
flow if you will with your work and that
natural instinct that we're talking
about today is busyness so if you live
and if you're a resident of the United
States of America and even if you're not
but if you are I would challenge that
your association so we associate things
with words again again I don't have a
whole lot of time to go into that from a
psychological standpoint though we
associate different things we're a niche
eventually words and things we kind of
interact with in an emotional state if
you will and so that association with
busy I would say is unhealthy and here's
some examples of what you may feel when
you're talking about being busy in your
job so if any of these statements kind
of resonate with you kind of put that in
the back your mind and think about that
because I don't think the thing the tip
that I'm going to give you today is
going to be able to be used in your team
until you start dealing with your own
personal unhealthy association with the
term busy and I'll prove that to you so
what do you think's easier do you think
doing this would be easier than this
I'll show you again do you think this
one is easier to do than this one which
one's easier does anyone think this
one's easier no no brave souls okay
yeah I would agree this one is easier
well why don't you do that with your
work
right why don't we do that with our work
so today what I want to tell you is I
want to introduce a concept to you you
may be familiar with if you study the
Kanban stuff it's one of the tenth you
know one of the principles that we talk
about when we're teaching Kanban and
that is limiting your work-in-progress
and you may immediately go well there's
no way in heck my boss is gonna let me
bring up any term around limiting
anything because we're always full full
force 100% all-out we've got to get this
done we don't have time to wait and
that's where you know you could say Paul
told you that it was good to limit your
work in progress because you're gonna
get more work done but you know we don't
know each other that well so you don't
have to take my word for this you can
actually take the word of a lot of
people that are way smarter than me that
have studied this and come up with a law
that's used throughout the Kanban
community and it's called littles law
now if the littles law police was here
today they would probably take me aback
and handcuff me with the definition I'm
gonna give you but I'm trying to give it
to you in a very simple term because in
Kanban the thing I love about Kanban the
most important thing for me is is that
it's very simplistic and approachable
many people come up to me and go oh it's
just a glorified tic-tac-toe board
what's the big deal
but it's actually the that simplicity to
me that's so powerful because you can
get so much more sophistication out of
your team
the further deeper in the pool you get
if you will so when the shallow end is
what we're going today so bear with me
as we go over just a real quick
high-level definition of littles law
which is if your team's busy do more if
your team is overburdened or really
really busy do less either way you're
actually going to produce more and
that's a law that's not something that
Paul's coming up with that's people that
are way smarter than me the thing I've
learned the most as I've starting to
studied and learned the lean community
and common community is people in the
con going community are very academic
they are like super smart so just take
that and I promise you especially if you
want to go do some research on littles
law or if you want to catch me in the
mixer afterwards I'd love to talk about
this I'm always a fan of talking about
Kanban so I want to leave you with one
more thing this is my favorite quote it
comes from the book essentialism by Greg
McKeown so I'm gonna read it to you
because I think it's that powerful the
word priority came into the English
language in the 1400s it stayed singular
the next 500 years let that sink in so I
want to leave you with one last thought
and that is I've found that many
development teams especially knowledge
work teams have difficulty delivering
software in a predictable fashion
especially if management only knows the
carrot or the stick mentality like
that's the only tools they have in their
tool belt and so that's why I want to
say that high-performing teams are teams
that have learned a language on how to
fight against their natural instincts
that create delay in their system and
they've been able to use that common
language to focus their team on flow and
how to improve the flow of their team so
as you go out today think about those
instincts I can only cover one today
obviously but my name is Paul
I teach Kanban I love it I've been doing
development for a while as well but yeah
if you have any questions right now we
have maybe 30 or 15 seconds or something
like that so yeah sorry I went long
sure so one way that I've done in the
classes that I teach I teach a full-day
class of this and one one thing that I
do is I do activities which is not
obviously necessarily you can do a hey
boss come over here we want to do this
cool activity to teach you something you
don't know that doesn't really go over
well however if you're able to introduce
them in that way maybe then I can send
you some videos on some of the
activities I've seen that teach people
like why multitasking and its really
mind-blowing like literally your natural
instinct is to do a bunch of things at
once and you think it's gonna be faster
and it's not however in your specific
scenario what I would recommend is
trying an experiment so take an approach
and go to your boss and say hey look for
the next sprint could we just implement
with limits well what does that mean
Paul like what do you mean by whip
limits well let's decide for each
activity that we do on our system maybe
you start with a Kanban board which
literally is that's the thing I love
about Kanban it works on top of whatever
you do today you do scrum you do
waterfall you do whatever you can put
Kanban on top of it because it's
literally the capstone that fits on top
of what you do today so you just start
with a common on board you start with
some whip limits on top of that just to
reduce the amount you're working on at
once and and try it out for a couple of
weeks maybe one sprint maybe two sprints
but you have to follow those limits you
can't just have them up there and then
not follow them right and you can even
have those conversations when the boss
comes to you and goes hey I need you to
work on these things like well we've met
the whip limit and we're in this
experiment phase can we not work on it
right now because of that and you push
it off that way I've seen that work on
teams you know because again that
experimentation mindset can be helpful
for you to try it out and see if it
works for your team yeah
any other questions and it was more well
it depends on what your yeah what your
throughput is right absolutely you need
to make sure that as your team you're
focusing on what is the next most
valuable thing for your client so you're
absolutely right if you're just pushing
through things because you're pushing
through things and you don't understand
how that applies to your customer you I
would definitely be on the front end of
that you want to make sure whatever
you're delivering is valuable the same
way if you're using sprints and scrum
right if you're sprint you're delivering
it's not valuable to your customer then
why are you doing it right so there yeah
absolutely it's not just about being
fast and efficient but it's also about
focusing the team on that customer for
sure
you